mais ce sont les sciences sociales je
m'appelle sylvain draps mais je suis
professeur de sciences sociales et de
géographie en belgique dans le
secondaire supérieur et aujourd'hui je
vais répondre à cette fameuse question
les sciences sociales
c'est quoi dans les sciences sociales il
y a le mot science est l'adjectif social
le social c'est le fait que tous les
individus depuis leur naissance jusqu'à
leur mort vive en interaction avec
d'autres personnes et de ce fait forment
des communautés et des sociétés c'est ça
le social c'est l'ensemble des échanges
que les individus entretiennent entre
eux ils arrivent toujours qu'un élève me
disent ah ouais et si on n'a pas de
contacts dans sa vie un confit tout seul
dans la forêt un bail a pas
d'interaction n'y a pas de sciences
sociales il n'y a pas de social du tout
il ya des moqueries
je leur réponds que déjà le fait de
n'être implique deux interactions au
minimum et que lhermitte ou l'enfant
élevé par des loups dans la jungle sont
des mythes
car même celui qui vit seul a toujours
besoin d'outils qui ont été fabriqués
par d'autres personnes personne ne peut
produire tout seul tous les produits et
services dont il a besoin
mais revenons-en à nos moutons les
sciences sociales sont donc les sciences
qui s'intéresse aux êtres humains en
interaction dans les sociétés et dans
les collectivités
mais qu'est ce qu'une science et puis
pourquoi les sciences sociales et pas la
science sociale
le petit robert donne la définition
suivante du mot science corp organisé de
connaissances ayant un objet déterminé
et reconnue et une méthode propre une
science et u10 donc un objet en vue de
produire des connaissances en utilisant
certaines méthodes
par exemple la physique pour objet
l'étude des lois de la matière inerte et
utilise certaines méthodes comme des
modèles mathématiques et des
expérimentations et cette définition
permet de comprendre pourquoi on parle
des sciences sociales au pluriel en
effet l'objet des sciences sociales ce
sont les interactions humaines
on l'a déjà dit mais cela reste très
général cet objet donc étudié de
différentes manières par différentes
disciplines avec différentes méthodes se
sont sales et sciences sociales
le sociologue étudie plus
particulièrement les liens
les interactions entre les individus et
les groupes d'individus il peut utiliser
des statistiques d observation d enquête
par questionnaire d entretien ou arriver
à certaines conclusions la science
politique s'intéresse quant à elle à la
manière dont les groupes et les sociétés
prennent des décisions collectives
comment fait-on pour décider à l'échelle
d'une société voire d'un groupe pour
étudier cela le politologue ou la
politologue peut utiliser des documents
d observation de documents comme par
exemple les travaux préparatoires à
l'adoption d'une loi mais aussi des
statistiques par exemple des résultats
aux différentes élections d'un pays où
d'une région
mais cela n'empêche pas d'utiliser les
outils déjà utilisée par le sociologue
l'économiste surtout s'il vient de
l'école néoclassique étudie la manière
dont les sociétés produisent consomment
et distribuer les biens et les services
dont elle a besoin
en utilisant des modèles mathématiques
comme par exemple modèle de l'offre et
de la demande
l'ethnologue étudie les pratiques des
différentes ethnies en recourant à
l'observation directe ou s'il vient à
lui même intégré les sociétés qu'il
entend comprendre l'observation
participants en résumé si on parle de
sciences sociales ou pluriel et non pas
de la science sociale c'est parce que
les disciplines qui les composent sont
très variés tant par leur objet que par
leurs méthodes
même si elles ont le même point de
départ le même objet d'étude les
interactions entre les femmes et les
hommes
les disciplines reprises sous le terme
les sciences sociales sont donc
nombreuses
désormais vous le savez nous avons déjà
parlé de la sociologie de la science
politique de la science économique et de
l'ethnologie mais il y en a bien
d'autres et on pourrait citer encore
sans être exhaustif inquiète pour
l'examen il faudra tout étudié la
géographie sociale qui analyse la
répartition des populations et des
phénomènes sociaux dans l'espace la
communication sociale qui s'intéresse
aux échanges d'informations entre des
individus ou des groupes d'individus la
criminologie qui tentent de comprendre
l'acte criminel ou encore
l'anthropologie qui retrace les
évolutions de l'humain tant au niveau
culturel qu'au niveau physique
ouais ok mais bon c'est quand même pas
des sciences mais peut-on vraiment
parler de science les sciences sociales
sont elles comparables à la physique à
la chimie ou aux mathématiques
évidemment l'objectif final des sciences
sociales n'est pas le même
celui des sciences dites exactes et
naturelles les sciences sociales ne
permettent pas d'établir de grandes lois
immuables qui serait vrai pour
l'éternité ni d'atteindre le niveau de
prédiction des sciences de la nature
cependant il ne faut pas tomber dans
l'excès inverse qui tend à considérer
les sciences sociales comme des sciences
molles bout ou au final on ne fait
qu'échanger son avis est le plus
convaincant l'emportera les sciences
sociales repose sur des méthodes
rigoureuses les conclusions auxquelles
aboutit ces sciences sociales sont
certes plus limité conscience naturel
mais elles permettent néanmoins de
comprendre ou d'expliquer bon nombre de
faits et de phénomènes sociaux
elles sont donc bien plus qu'un simple
échange de points de vue comme certains
détracteurs des sciences sociales
tentent souvent de le faire croire cette
vidéo est terminée vous trouverez
plaindre sur supplémentaires sur le blog
de la société
mais aussi dans le descriptif de cette
vidéo je vous souhaite beaucoup
d'amusement avec les sciences sociales
et je vous dis à très bientôt dans une
prochaine vidéo